If anybody knows how to start a party,
it's my brother, Andrew.
Or should I say...
the Jig Conductor.
That's fine. It's so cute.
It's so good.
No, Mom. If anybody sees that,
I'm gonna get put on a watch list.
I can't believe college is over.
You have a job now, or...
We're not allowed to talk about jobs
at the Bat Mitzvah party.
So, you either don't have a job,
or you have a bad job.
How much does a party starter
get paid, I wonder.
I have a bad job, yeah.
Honey, I'm not just saying this
because I'm your mother.
But I feel like
you're way ahead of the game.
Who's that?
That's a mom and her kid.
Do you two dance?
We're not feelin' it right now.
How about I bet you
three hundred dollars
that I can get her to dance.
I will give you a thousand dollars.
She really likes you.
I really like her.
Tonight is the night that you and Lola
dance your booties off.
Oh! I don't know how to moonwalk.
Do you think he would be
a good sitter, for you?
I do not do well with sitters.
But I think it might be
a bit different with Andrew.
Do you wanna meet my hamster?
Yeah.
I wanna thank you
for being so kind to Lola.
Easiest thing in the world.
I'm having more fun now
than I did the whole night.
Do you have a husband?
I have a fiance.
I hear you're a great party starter.
I hear you're a great professional lawyer.
Much to figure out, after college.
Giving your heart to somebody
is the most...
perplexing thing.
You can't just decide
that you love somebody.
-Yes, you can.
-No, you can't.
Yes, you can.
We don't need you to babysit anymore.
Why?
Lots of reasons.
Are you drunk right now, Son?
Everything is just a mess.
Growing up is hard.
Is he your soulmate?
Do you believe in soulmates?
I think we all have
like a ton of soulmates.
How many soulmates?
For you, like four.
How many do you have?
Like, twelve... hundred.